the girl on the train is directed by
Tate Taylor and stars Emily Blunt and is
the adaptation of the extremely popular
novel of the same name Emily Blunt plays
a very broken woman who is dealing with
alcoholism who rides a train every day
and lives vicariously through the people
that she views through the windows she
makes up stories about how she thinks
they may live and these fantasies she
develops with these people in her head
are what keep her going every day until
she sees something that shocks her and
leads her down a very dark path to a
place where whodunit mystery develops
and we as the audience have to figure
out what is truth and what is fiction as
this character also tries to figure out
the same thing the marketing for this
movie was really intense it really beat
you over the head was trying to make you
think this movie was going to be
incredible a lot of people have compared
it to gone girl because of similar
themes every poster had the tagline what
did she see in big bold letters all the
commercials said this the thriller that
shocked the world was what I kept
hearing and so naturally I was excited
for this movie because of course it was
going to shock me to write in reality
this is an emotionally vapid dull
Lifetime channel original movie given
the Hollywood treatment and an extremely
overhyped marketing campaign to get
everyone really interested in a film
that's pretty much emotionally
weightless for the first few minutes of
this movie I was like man Emily Blunt is
really delving deep into this role this
could be a really impressive film I
can't wait to see where this story goes
but as the movie progresses and
progresses and continuously progresses
and keeps progressing I kept waiting for
the movie to start and I think maybe
about an hour in it starts everything
before that is just a train ride pun
intended to a destination that you're
waiting to eventually get to and once
you get there it's okay like you're like
all right that's interesting but then
the movie divulge 'iz into extreme
melodramatic territory where characters
make decisions that are purely based on
hopefully shocking you or maybe getting
that extra dramatic punch in there when
it really doesn't seem to work there are
really fine performances in this movie
and
blunt is a lot better than this movie
deserves Rebecca Ferguson who was
excellent in rogue nation is also really
good here and Haley Bennett at times is
very good Luke Evans is also good in
this film Allison Janney shows up and is
excellent as a detective who's trying to
figure out what's going on but for the
most part the performers in this movie
are entirely reliant on whether or not
the screenplay decides to give them good
dialogue for the scene or Twilight fan
fiction dialogue the dialogue in this
screenplay goes in so many different
directions it goes from being good to
acceptable to awful in the flash of a
few minutes
look my next criticism is going to
contain mild spoilers so I'm just going
to warn you this is my best way to
describe this film though it starts out
fairly okay and you're like this could
be compelling this could be an
interesting narrative and by the end of
it you realize it's just one of those
movies where every character has had sex
with each other and they want to try to
wring every little bit of drama out of
it they can this film has some good
performances it has a story that could
have been interesting but the execution
especially from Tate Taylor does not fit
this film I found his direction to be
very flat filled with odd choices like
using low frame rate photography which
really made it look very ugly sometimes
and I just did not feel that his
direction really added much to this
story in fact I think it detracted from
it and this is coming from the guy who
made a movie the help which I thought
was good I don't really know what
happened with this film this is a film
that has good marketing and a good
performance and that's about it
I'm going to give the girl on the train
a c-minus
this film is just about every
opportunity it had to be a great film I
don't know what happened sorry this
review was a little bit late and that my
new release reviews for this weekend
have been late my wife and I took a
vacation to Tennessee at a cabin in the
woods
to film our upcoming 4th annual
Halloween scary movie nights special
we're going to be talking about cabin in
the woods horror films and we did a
really fun skit that also proceeds
throughout our video at a cabin in the
woods I can't wait to share that with
you guys later in October it's going to
be a lot of fun you guys are the best
thank you so much as always for watching
and if you like this you can click right
here and get stuck my nice
[Music]
you